alors ce ne sont pas exactement des
maladie de kawasaki les pédiatres qui
suivent évidemment avec attention ces
maladies rares
c'est syndrome inflammatoire multi
systémique atypique pédiatrique qui
touche des enfants de deux cinq ans à 20
ans nous leur avons demandé de le mettre
en place une surveillance active c'est à
dire de nous signaler tout nouveau cas
nous sommes aujourd'hui à 152 cas depuis
le 1er mars
nous étudions à chaque fois si ce cas
est lié ou pas à la maladie qu'ovide à
la présence ou non du virus dans les
jours qui ont précédé cette apparition
de symptômes multiples nous avons pour
98 cas un lien possible avec la maladie
pour d'autres cas une investigation
toujours en cours et même pour dans de
nombreux autres cas pas de lien avec la
maladie dont vous voyez qu'il faut
pouvoir faire le tri il ya eu un pic en
mi avril une diminution régulière depuis
mais je tiens à rassurer les parents il
faut si on a le moindre doute devant une
fièvre persistante devant une fatigue de
l'enfant consulter rapidement leur
médecin généraliste ou le pédiatre et il
ya une évolution favorable lorsque les
enfants sont pris en charge en milieu
spécialisé sous un traitement spécifique
et donc l'évolution est en général très
favorable